ich war diese Woche wieder mit meinem
trödeltrupp unterwegs und wir haben in
Buxtehude das Zimmer meiner Nichten
renoviert es gab Höhen Timo es gab
tiefen oh nein es wurde wieder alles
komplett chaotisch
aber die Reaktion ist unbezahlbar
ich habe die letzten zwei Wochen hier
mit Anni verbracht und wir haben auch
die Oma von Anni aufgepasst auf den Hund
aufgepasst und haben uns einfach schöne
zwei Wochen gemacht dann kam immer auf
mich zu mit einer kooperationsanfrage
und ich dachte das ist die Gelegenheit
und für meine Nichten ein komplettes
room Make-Over zu machen denn sie
schlafen schon seit langem auf Betten
die ja so ein bisschen in die Tage
gekommen sind und ursprünglich dachte
ich mir gut dann stell ich den zwei neue
Betten rein dann ist die ganze Idee ein
bisschen eskaliert und ich habe einen
komplettes Zimmer geplant also welche
Möbel kommen rein welche Möbel kommen
raus welche Wandfarbe machen all diese
Fragen habe ich mir eine Woche lang
gestellt habe alles bestellt und das ist
jetzt dabei rausgekommen
[Musik]
dieses Video ist nur möglich durch die
Unterstützung unseres
Kooperationspartners Emma bei Emma
findest du alles rund ums Bett Kissen
Decken und vor allem Matratzen die Emma
one Federkernmatratze ist die
beliebteste Matratze der Welt behaupte
ich jetzt mal aber später erzähle ich
euch noch mehr dazu es ist natürlich
schwierig ihr Zimmer umzugestalten
während sie da sind also musste ich sie
schon mal vorwarnen es ist natürlich
auch nett wenn wir da drin ein vorher
Film das sie vielleicht Zeit haben ihr
Zimmer aufzuräumen hi na ihr beiden ähm
also aber euer Zimmer sollte morgen
aufgeräumt sein ja
mehr sage ich nicht alles klar bis
morgen tschüss
ey der Gesichtsausdruck krass ja okay ja
Phase 1 ist eingeleitet an diesem
Projekt liebe ich am meisten diese
Vorfreude zu haben und sich zu fragen
wie werden wohl die Leute reagieren wenn
Sie das Endergebnis sehen und am
nächsten Tag bin ich dann mit Kartons
nach Buxtehude Gefahren
hallo unser Zimmer wird neu gemacht
nein also ich habe ein paar
Umzugskartons mitgebracht bis morgen
sollte euer ganzes Zimmer eingepackt
sein
danke danke
also das Leila auch gleich erkannt hat
dass ich ihr Zimmer neu mache das passt
so gut zu ihr aber sie liegt halt auch
nicht falsch ne
geht doch die letzte wurde schon seit
paar Monaten
und jetzt kommst du so um die Ecke neues
Zimmer aber warte kriegen wie fühlt euch
gut sehr gut ja seid ihr aufgeregt ja
ein bisschen
Leute ich habe gar nicht gesagt dass es
neues Zimmer gibt ich will einfach nur
dass sie richtig gut aufräumen und dann
ging es auch schon los wir sind morgens
angekommen und haben erstmal die Möbel
rausgeräumt das ganze würde ich
natürlich nicht schaffen mit der
reizenden Hilfe von Frau aggressiv
erstmal warm machen
meins oh das habe ich mir gekauft als
ich nach Berlin gekommen bin und wir tun
jetzt einfach mal bis zur Tür so als ob
wir das machen und danach Tricks Timo
okay mit mir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geschafft der Raum ist leer und er ist
so riesig wenn der leer ist kennt ihr
das wenn man umzieht und dann erstmal
merkt so viel Platz habe ich die
Schränke sind das einzige was bleibt das
sind ganz super tolle Kleiderschränke
und da haben wir nicht gesehen warum wir
sie ändern müssten einen Plan gemacht
wie das Zimmer jetzt alles so alles so
stehen soll aber bevor wir diesen Plan
umsetzen können und alle Möbel aufbauen
müssen erstmal streichen aber dieses
Projekt wäre natürlich nicht möglich
gewesen ohne mein Kooperationspartner
immer
Team und ich schlafen schon seit langem
mit Emma Produkten und sind super
zufrieden und meine Nichten machen
gerade ihren Abschluss also brauchen sie
viel Ruhe und Entspannung und dafür
gönnen wir den ein paar Emma Produkte
und übrigens ihr habt auch was davon
denn mit meinem Code mal warne könnt ihr
5% on top auch schon auf die bestehenden
Rabatte noch zusätzlich sparen gönnt
euch guten Schlaf
[Musik]
ich habe gerade gehört dass die Möbel
angekommen sind und meine Schwester
stöhnt da unten schon ein bisschen weil
es ein bisschen viel geworden ist
Vanessa vanessa hat sie gesagt das ist
das schlimmste was ich zu mir sagen kann
Vanessa vanessa ist übersetzt
Youtube ich bin Tine Wittler das ist für
RTL ja Andi sag doch mal was witziges
jetzt gibt es ein kleines Tutorial wie
ihr eure Klamotten beim Malen nicht
dreckig macht und zwar nimmt ihre
Klamotten dreht sie einmal um und zieht
sie wieder an und so mach dir nur die
Rückseite dreckig achso das machen wir
auch natürlich mit der Hose aber ganz
ehrlich ich habe das auf der Fashion
Week gesehen let's go malen 3 2 1
[Musik]
der erste Strich Leute damit
die der Anfang etwas ganz Großes
an dieser Stelle vielen Dank an meine
Schwester dass sie uns geholfen hat ich
glaube ohne sie wäre das alles ein
bisschen langsamer gelaufen ich hatte
ursprünglich nur vor die beiden bunten
Wände weiß zu streichen aber mein
Schwager und Maler Ahmed wirst du
natürlich dass die anderen Wände halt
auch nachgestrichen werden müssen weil
wenn die anderen so clean aussehen und
dann da irgendwie noch so Flecken oder
so drauf sind gut das hat dann wirklich
alles ein bisschen länger gedauert als
geplant aber das ganze Projekt hat auch
alles länger gedauert als geplant und
dann musste man natürlich nur eine
zweite Schicht drauf machen und als die
dann getrocknet ist konnten wir die
Möbel an ihre Position stellen und mit
dem Aufbau anfangen
[Musik]
ich glaube nach diesen Tagen können wir
alle keine Schubladen mehr sehen weil
wir so viele Schubladen aufgebaut haben
zwischendurch ist auch mal so ein
kleiner Wettkampf entstanden also wer
kann einen Möbelstück schneller aufbauen
es hat ein bisschen Druck ausgelöst aber
uns auch alle vorangetrieben
mit eurer Arroganz ich spüre das bis
hierhin und jetzt was müssen wir jetzt
machen okay ihr seid einmal schlauer als
Vanessa
warte wir machen jetzt den Ton an anami
hallo
ist nicht mal echt
hallo hallo ein Tag eins haben wir schon
mal die Gardinen gebohrt
zum einen damit wir die Schreibtische
schon hinstellen können und das alles
Finales zum anderen damit wir einen Tag
zwei so um 14 Uhr fertig werden Spoiler
wir wurden nicht um 14 Uhr fertig
Gardinen sind angebracht wir müssen
jetzt schon mal die Gardinen anbringen
weil der Schreibtisch kommt und es kommt
hier ein ganz langer Schreibtisch hin
ähm weil sie sich natürlich schminken
müssen die Schule arbeiten machen müssen
und dafür braucht man Platz vorher
hatten wir diese kleinen Schreibtische
das kann man sicherlich anschauen und
jetzt
unser ursprünglicher Plan war es von 8
bis 18 Uhr dort zu sein ein guter
Arbeitstag
aber es ist 9:30 Uhr geworden und wir
waren ziemlich fertig also
Video das Bett gestellt hast alle hier
am machen also eigentlich wollten wir
morgen die Betten aufbauen aber jetzt
haben wir uns entschieden dass heute zu
machen damit wir schon mal gucken können
wie die Möbel stehen weil wir uns ein
bisschen verkalkuliert haben bzw ja ist
alles so nicht ganz perfekt so wie uns
das vorgestellt haben wir hatten so
stimmungshöhen und Tiefen und da war die
Stimmung wirklich am Tiefpunkt wir haben
nicht das geschafft was wir schaffen
wollten wir wollten eigentlich alle
Möbel fertig haben aber gut so ist das
halt heute ist Tag 2 und wir müssen uns
richtig ranhalten denn heute ist auch
der große reveal für meine Nichten und
ich bin so gespannt was sie denken wir
machen heute ein bisschen Deko ein
bisschen aufbauen also ja wir machen
dann mal ein Tag zwei haben wir erstmal
das zweite Bett aufgebaut und dann gegen
die Diskussion los wie wir die Betten
denn hinstellen wie das mit plenia nun
mal so ist man macht sich ein und am
Ende kommt alles nicht so hin wie man
sich das überlegt hat wir wollten die
Betten so hinstellen dass sie zueinander
aber dann hätten sie nur noch so ein
ganz dünnen Weg gehabt um da
durchzukommen das hat wirklich nicht so
gut funktioniert dann haben wir ein Bett
an die Wand gestellt das andere in den
Raum aber das hat die Symmetrie kaputt
gemacht die wir durch die Schreibtische
schon erreicht haben und das wollten wir
eigentlich weiter so durchziehen aber
mein Neffe salir kam wirklich auf die
beste Idee und zwar dass wir die
Kommoden in die Mitte stellen was
erstmal komisch wirkte weil das wie so
eine Wand war die ziemlich massiv wirkte
wenn man sieht im Zeitraffer dass wir
die Kommoden in die Mitte gestellt haben
und wir haben den Kleiderschrank noch
mal umgestellt und jetzt ist dieses
Zimmer wirklich symmetrisch ey FF wir
können uns aber am Ende alle darauf
einigen dass wir das so machen nur haben
wir jetzt die Rückseite von den Kommoden
so offen im Raum stehen gehabt und da
hatte ich mal wieder eine tolle Idee und
zwar kann man so Pinnwand Kork als
Platten kaufen und die legen wir einfach
auf die Rückseite und so haben die
Mädels auf jeder Seite noch eine
Pinnwand nachdem wir aber alle Möbel so
hingestellt haben dass alle auch
wirklich jeder in diesem Haus damit
zufrieden ist konnten wir endlich bohren
also ich kann euch auch wirklich sagen
born ist gar nicht so kompliziert wie
ich immer dachte ich habe irgendwie
Angst davor gehabt weil Bohrmaschinen so
laut sind und das so eine aggressive
Tätigkeit ist dass ich das immer auf
meinen Vater geschoben habe auf
irgendwelche Handwerker aber an sich ist
es ein Loch in die Wand machen und das
kriegt man dann doch schon hin nur das
Ausmessen das Ausmessen ist so nervig
und dann haben wir gebohrt gebohrt noch
eine Lampe an Geburt noch Regale Angebot
das ist ein Regal und noch mehr geworden
und dann wollten wir den Spiegel
anbohren das hat aber nicht geklappt
weil wir zum Glück so ein
Messgerät hatten und dieses Messgerät
hat immer rot angezeigt das heißt da war
Strom Metall alles hinter der Wand und
das riskieren natürlich nicht
[Musik]
Leute es ist ganz wichtig dass ihr kein
Teppichmesser nimmt sondern das Messer
was von Emma mit beigefügt wird denn das
ist viel sicherer und Timo hat ein ganz
kleinen Schnitt reingemacht zum Glück
war es aber nicht die Liegefläche und
der Schnitt ging nur in den ersten Stoff
rein Schock unseres Lebens hallo und
herzlich Willkommen zu meinem Tutorial
wie starte ich mein Bett mit Emma
Produkten aus
zuerst braucht ihr ein Bett und
vielleicht kurze bettlampe aller Zeiten
dann braucht ihr eine Matratze von Emma
sie fühlt sich mit Luft
boah guck mal wie riesig das geworden
ist das heißt für mich wirklich wir sind
fast fertig
aber denk dran bevor ihr euch jetzt da
drauf legen wollt muss sie noch
aus uns wurden jetzt zwei Emma one
Federkernmatratzen zur Verfügung
gestellt zwei Sommerdecken und meine
geliebten flauschige Kisten und falls es
noch nicht wusstet man kann 100 Nächte
Probeschlafen und der Matratzenkern hat
10 Jahre Garantie und mir jetzt mal im
Ernst vielen Dank immer dass ihr mir
solche Projekte hier ermöglicht und das
ist einfach ein Herzensprojekt also
danke und übrigens könnt ihr im
frühlingsseil jetzt noch mit meinem
Rabattcode malwanne 5% on top sparen und
keine Sorge falls jetzt im
frühlingshelfer verpasst habt der
übrigens bis zum 15.06 geht mein Code
ist ein halbes Jahr gültig also viel
Spaß beim shoppen und jetzt geht's
weiter mit dem Video anni hat zum Glück
alles aufgeräumt so dass wir dann die
Kork Wand basteln konnten wir kleben
unsere Pinnwand Korb Platte jetzt an
unseren Schrank und das ist hier ein
kleines DIY und dann einfach drauf danke
selber zu Hause machen wollt kauft euch
Gott schneidet es zu klebt hinten dran
oder Heimat ist dran ist und dann auch
später aufgefallen sein und fertig ihr
habt eine tolle Pinnwand hinter eurer
Kommode und jetzt kommt endlich der
beste Moment das Dekorieren hallo und
willkommen zu meinem kleinen Unboxing
ich habe Schreibtischlampen gekauft und
diese Schreibtischlampen sind einfach so
cool weil sie so gut zu mir passen und
das ist mein kleines Ding was ich hier
rein packe von mir
guck mal die Influenza Lampe
oh mein Gott das ist meine absolute
wow ich habe ein bisschen Deko gekauft
für Leila natürlich pink und für Soraya
grün ganz wichtig
so kleine Kisten für den Schreibtisch
dass sie da so vielleicht so ein paar
komische Sachen reinmachen können also
kann man sich das so auf den Tisch
stellen und damit diese Kissen am Anfang
nicht leer sind haben wir den kleine
Gummis reingemacht für Leila natürlich
grün an dieser Stelle Leila liebt rosa
jetzt nicht so sehr oh Mist hier
natürlich das für später damit das alles
hier noch Cosi aussieht aber was haben
wir denn noch eine grüne Kerze und eine
Hose
für so einfach für irgendwelche
schnellen Stifte oder so auf dem
Schreibtisch und unsere Vasen und damit
Leuten jetzt die Deko auf dem Regal ein
[Musik]
und eins ist jetzt wirklich passiert es
kam zwei Möbelstücke nicht an Regale die
eigentlich hier stehen sollten wo dann
so Ordner und große Sachen reinkommen
können ja die sind jetzt nicht gekommen
die kommen glaube ich morgen oder so
aber dann ist es jetzt halt so also
manchmal gehen halt Pläne einfach nicht
auf ich bin ein bisschen Zeit aber ja
gut ich meine die haben jetzt erstmal
genug Stauraum es war noch sehr süß weil
der kleinste Sohn von meiner Schwester
hat dann immer von dem Zeug was die
Mädels aus dem Zimmer rausgeholt haben
irgendwelche Bilderrahmen gefunden
irgendwelche Steine irgendwelche Vasen
und hat dann immer gefragt so oh das
passt doch auch super hier rein und das
Beste daran ist die Reaktion zu sehen
und die bekommt dir jetzt also Augen zu
lassen ne ja wir kennen ja wir müssen
die Augen wirklich zulassen
okay
[Musik]
ihr seid im
zu lassen die eine kommt auf die Seite
[Applaus]
1 2 3
[Musik]
was Leila deine Seite ist das hier
Soraya deine Seite ist das hier oh mein
Gott diese wir haben diese hat
ihr seht das ist sehr gespiegelt jetzt
also hier ist krass
bin ist diese Lampe hier
oha mit Touch geil
wir waren immer so ja wo sollen wir uns
angucken wo sollen wir sehen uns ja
wollen rausgehen das ist so schön
ich kann nicht mehr oh mein Gott und
hier so ein Spiegel Bella guck das dann
unser kleiner Spiegel und hier so hey
das Licht hast du das gecheckt da kann
man Handy rein machen
hä aber so was habt ihr bitte aus diesem
Zimmer gemacht ja Schmink und
Schreibtisch Schmink und Schreibtisch
also ich bin im Zimmer gemacht habe ich
habe gehört ihr mögt keine Gardinen aber
im Sommer wird es immer so warm und das
sind sogar die die halten die Temperatur
ein bisschen nach draußen korrekt und
dann könnt ihr sie ganz einfach
ich auch nicht
ich bin geschockt wirklich echt schön
und jetzt sagen wir alle danke immer
danke ihr seid die besten leg Dich rein
oh mein Gott ich finde wir haben ein
richtig guten Job gemacht und falls du
da draußen ein Baumarkt bist ein
Einrichtungshaus oder irgendwas womit
man solche Projekte umsetzen kann
schreibt uns wir haben da Bock drauf ich
will das noch mehr machen das macht
einfach tierisch Spaß ich habe auf
Tränen gehofft und ich habe sie bekommen
sie haben zwar nicht los geweint was ein
bisschen schade ist weil sie weinen
eigentlich wegen allem aber in der
ersten Minute habe ich die Tränen in den
Augen gesehen wie sie sich aufgebaut
haben die beiden haben das voll verdient
das sind so nette zwei Mädels und hier
einmal liebe Grüße an Leila und Soja ich
hoffe euch gefällt das Zimmer und wir
sehen uns dann nächste Mal hoffentlich
mit einem genauso fantastischen Video
und bis dann tschüss eure Tine Wittler